what I found at school today what is it
I have no idea gets a tampon girl shove
it up their buttholes to stop babies
from coming out and eighth-grader told
me that I'm having a party tomorrow.you
is yeah can throw a Lucas tongue you're
so random they're my best friends we did
everything together doesn't make girls
to the party you know that means drama
no kissing you do not want to go to the
storms party not knowing you have a kiss
rickets fly on my neighbor she's a total
nymphomaniac
she starts fires no she's a nymphomaniac
someone who has sex on land and sea this
is what happens when you don't respect
women I respect women my mom is my best
friend what about me but that's gonna
kill me Jim this is how we get the
journal back good sure there's mama
you took my bag oh my god there's Molly
in there okay who's Molly because she's
not with us Jesus
here's the plan I'm gonna go to the
party with a beer so everyone knows that
I'm cool what do you have your pants
butt like this ever since I was a baby
it's kind of embarrassing I'm guessing
you're not the popular kids in school
[Music]
I'm fine oh hell no if you don't get to
that party I'll die party
you guys are like seven fingers like
kids between Oh gummy vitamins know how
things work
[Music]
my first club and in North swing
what are you doing that's one is for
sexing people do sex on
[Music]
you